مرحبا كواليسنا اليوم كلها من مهرجان
البحر الاحمر السينمائي الدولي لانه في
كثير مواضيع حكينا فيها مع كثير من النجوم
نبدا نشرتنا مع جورج خباز اللي التقينا
فيه بعد الكثير من الجدل اللي اثاره فيلم
اصحاب
الماضي
الجديد حصريه لكواليس واللي هيكون مع
النجمه امل عرفه
الو الو مين معي الو
عندي هلا
مسلسل من عشر حلقات لكن كوميدي ببلش باول
شهر واحد على منصه شاهد
انتاج الصباح شركه الصباح
وبطولتي انا والرائعه امل عرفه اخراج
[موسيقى]
الخلاط في اليوتيوب
اللي تعرفوهم ولما سالناهم في الخلاط اللي
نعرفه قالوا ما غيرنا اي شيء
صغير
الفنان اللي من الحجاز الفنان اللي من
الرياض القصه اللي من نجد القصه اللي من
الحجاج
هي الخلاط اليوتيوب واا نحافظ عليه بس
بصوره افضل وننقل الى درجه افضل العمل
الفيلم تحديدا يعتمد على الجروب اكثر
والتيم اذا ما كان فاهم بعد مستحيل العمل
يمشي وحيوقف من اول او ثاني يوم تصوير
[موسيقى]
واخيرا تم عرض ولي اول مره فيلم بين
الرمال اللي طال انتظار وهو الفيلم
السعودي الاول اليوم صور بالكامل في اليوم
مع كاس ممثلين سعودي ايضا بالكامل الفيلم
بيحكي عن واحده من القصه الموروثه الشهيره
جدا عندنا وهي قصه مخاوي الذيب اللي
تحديدا صارت عام 27 ولكل احد روايه مختلفه
عنها انعرض ضمن المسابقه الرسميه بمهرجان
البحر الاحمر السينما الدولي مع ابطاله
رائد وكان لنا معهم هذه اللقاءات كثير
يعني من كل منطقه السعوديه فيها همم يعني
فارجو من القصه نفسها فانا قدرت اخذ اجزاء
معينه يعني 40% من النص كان مبني على
الاهداف الحقيقيه 60% انا حاولت اني اعالج
اجراميه
واضح نقدر ندرس القصه بالشكل السينما
الاخضر الناس دائما تحب الواقع فهي قصه
ريم همم كل اللي قاموا قاموا في سعوديين
همم يعني حاولنا نتكلم بلهجه نفس المنطقه
اللي صارت فيها الحدث القسم مره حلوه
الصراحه همم كمان شجعني وجود رائد ممثل تو
طالع متحمس فانا ابغى اشوف هو كيف حيطلع
طبعا اسئله كثيره الحذاء
كانت ماسكه اداره مهرجان الجونه السينمائي
واللي ما نعرف اذا راح يرجع او لا معه انه
يعني كل الاشارات يقول انه ما راح يرجع
بحسب الصحافه المصريه الا انه بشرى كانت
متواجده في جده في مهرجان البحر الاحمر
على رغبتها
بالعوده للمهرجانات لكن هذه المره ما تبغى
الحمل اللي كان عليها ايام الجونه وانها
هي بدها مهام اسهل واداريه اكثر من المهم
التنفي كمان مع هذا الحوار ايش رايكم
نتعرف
على الموضوع ويبقى عنده خبره وتنقل خبرتك
للاخرين انا قعدت خمس سنين اشتغل بيدي
يعني اشمر وانزل واقعد في الملعب واشتغل
همم
ولكن مش هينفع اغيب عن هذا العالم خالص
لانه باحس ان انا عندي شغف كبير مش سهله
تلاقيه عند اي احد انه يعني يتحقق على
الارض بشكل تنفيذ يعني فان شاء الله برده
موجوده بس من غير ما يجيء على حسابك يا
مطربه ولا كممثل
[موسيقى]
واخيرا توقف مع جديد بعض النجوم من هنا
وهناك قاعد اشتغل همم يعني في التحضيرات
في المثالي كاخراج اللي هو حياه فيلم
خليجي مغربي قصته شوي مختلفه بموضوع شوي
حساسه
همم مع التلفزيون السعودي
مغلق للصيانه همم ومستنيه عرض اولاد عادي
[موسيقى]